hello today we're going to
discuss erm for probabilistic
classification
so the key idea is that we have a
probabilistic classifier
g sub theta which depends on a parameter
theta it takes as
input u and it returns
to us a probability distribution over
the target set
and we're going to choose the theta by
erm
or regularized drm as we usually do
and we want to judge the performance of
the probabilistic classifier
using the average negative log
likelihood
on a test data set
and our data set remember what it
consists of it consists
of n points u1
through un and v1 through vn
and we're producing going to produce
corresponding
distributions p hat 1 through p hat n
which are our predictions at each of
those
data points u1 through un
and then we're going to compare our
predictions
p hat i with the true value
v i so in order to do that we need a
loss function
and the loss function has to be able to
compare two things
a p hat and a v and the p
hat is a distribution on our
target set script v and
the v is actually an element of script v
and so um so we're comparing things that
aren't
really like um
one thing to notice here is that p hat
is actually a
probability distribution it's a function
and so we're feeding
in to this function l
another function and a v
which is just a one of our possible
targets
and so once we've got such a thing we
are going to look at the average
loss one on n sum from is one to n
the loss of p hat i and v i
we're going to choose the theta to
minimize the average loss
and if we're doing regularized drm then
we'll have a regularization
function r of theta and we'll minimize
the average loss plus lambda times rf
theta
now the particular uh
loss of interest is going to be this
thing
lce um and what it is
is it's the negative log likelihood
of v under the distribution p hat
and so remember that we computed the
negative log
likelihood of our entire set
of p's and v's
assuming that all of the visa were
independent um
and so here we're just looking at one of
those for a single data point
and we're looking at the negative log
likelihood of getting
that particular v under a particular
distribution
p hat and this is called lce
the ce stands for cross entropy so this
is
also called the cross entropy loss
and it's just the negative log of the
probability of the outcome
v when you look at this it's important
to realize that
it really is a function of two things
it's a function of p
hat and it's a function of v and that
function
is of course a composition operation
composed with a
negative log operation we're taking
p hat and v and we're evaluating p hat
at the point v
um and of course we can do that because
p hat is a function
um now because
uh p hat is uh
less than or equal to one well the
negative log of it must be greater than
or equal to zero
and the only way you can have the the
the
negative log equal to zero is if uh
p hat is equal to one that is means
where would that would mean we would be
completely certain about the outcome in
other words the probability of getting
that particular v would be
would be one and the probability of
getting any other v therefore would be
zero
so that's when our prediction
is that the true v is actually the v
we're evaluating at
and with a hundred percent probability
um and so we want the negative log
likelihood uh to be small
so that uh as much as close as possible
we're getting p hat of v close to one
now um
this cross entropy loss
it certainly is a loss function but it's
a loss function which is aimed
specifically at probabilistic prediction
and this is a little different from when
we did erm
for either deterministic classification
or for
regression there we had a loss function
which was a function of y
hat and y and
it was comparing y hat and y the
predicted value y hat with the actual
value y
and those are both the same kind of
quantities
they were both vectors in our m
and here this is a little different in
two ways
first of all our prediction isn't a y
hat but it's a p hat
so it's a function it's a probability
distribution
and the second is is that the the second
argument of the last function
isn't an embedded v it's actually the
raw target b um
and of course the raw target b is simply
one of the
um one of the original target set
script v um and we don't need to
embed it into uh uh into rm in order to
be able to evaluate a loss and so we
don't do that
so we can certainly compute the
empirical risk on the entire data set
now that we've got a loss function
we simply compute one on n sum from i is
one to n
of lce of uh
the p hat i that's with v i
and p hat i is the prediction at the ith
value of u and v i is the true
value of the target variable in the ith
data point
and p height i is itself generated by
the predictor it's g
of ui um
now one nice thing about this is that
this is actually our performance metric
and so i remember that one of the things
we did in
regression and deterministic
classification was that we had
something we really cared about such as
the
name and pearson loss but we couldn't
actually
minimize that and so we used a proxy
loss
we used a loss function which was a
replacement for
the true quantity of interest the true
performance metric
and here we don't need to do that
because the average value
of the cross entropy loss is the average
negative log likelihood which is a
performance metric that we care about it
is
the probability of
seeing those data points bi under p hat
or it is the likelihood of the joint
distribution
p at once with p hat n um
uh the uh now remember we've seen
already
that uh when you have a constant
predictor that means p hat i doesn't
depend on i
um that you can work out what this
quantity is and that is the cross
entropy so the average cross entropy
loss
is the cross entropy when uh p hat is a
constant
so when we're interpreting this we think
about it as
a measure of implausibility
the cross entropy loss of p hat and v is
large when v is unplausible
and uh distribution p hat
and it's small when v is likely under
distribution p hat
and so people have names for this kind
of thing people might call it surprise
or perplexity
now um
we would like to be able to do um
predictors to use predictors which
generate vectors right so we've
certainly seen that if we've got
a a tree um
then we can simply label the leaves of
the tree
with probabilities probability
distributions
and that's enough we could simply
evaluate the output of that predictor
in the uh
in the loss function
however if we've got say a linear
predictor
or
certain other types of predictors then
the predictor produces a
a vector and um
of course we can't just use that vector
as a probability distribution it might
not be
non-negative it might not sum up to one
and so we need a way around that
if we were doing point classification
what we would do is we would unembed a
vector y
hat in rk
by uh just uh picking
the corresponding target to be v sub i
where i is the
uh index of the representative psi
i which is the closest of the
representatives
to y hat
and that is great it maps the
vector y hat in rk into the target set
script
v that's not quite
what we want to do here we want to
unembed
and map y hat into
a probability distribution on the target
set script v and there's a
way of doing this which is very common
and that's the following on embedding
it's called the logistic map or the soft
dog max function
and what we do is we define
p hat of v k to be the exponential
of y hat k divided by
the sum of the exponentials of y hat j
and this is a map which for each
k gives us p hat of v k
it maps a vector y hat in rk to a
probability distribution
and you can see that if you sum from k
is one
up to capital k of p hat v k you get one
and you can see that because it's the
ratio of an exponential and the sum of
exponentials
it's a non-negative number so it
certainly
satisfies the two fundamental
requirements for
a probability distribution
and this map sigma um uh it has
lots of names um i guess the community
cannot agree as to what the right thing
to think of it
right way to name it is and people call
it the logistic map
people call it an activation function
and
they use it as an activation function in
a neural network
people call the inverse link function
the software max function
the normalized exponential or the soft
max function
let's take a look at it slightly more
closely
so what does it do well the exponential
is mapping the real line to
the non-negative half of the real line
and so what the exponentials are doing
is replacing all of the entries all of
the components of
y hat with non-negative numbers
and then the division what that's doing
is normalizing it
it's arranging for the components
of p hat to sum up to one
so we can see that we are getting a
probability distribution
now you can also see that for example if
you take y
hat your predicted
output of your predictor and add a
constant to each entry
but then that doesn't affect p hat
um you can also see that if you increase
one of the components say
k now if you increase y hat k
then that will increase the probability
uh p hat v k and decrease all the others
because
the others have to be chosen to sum up
to one
and so it is larger y
hats correspond to larger probabilities
but it can never equal either zero or
one
um uh p hat
v k is close to zero when y hat k
is much smaller than all the others
and p hat v k is close to one when y hat
k is much larger than all the other
components of y
hat
there's one more special case which is
when y hat is zero
and when y hat is zero well then you end
up with p hat of v k is the uniform
distribution 1 over k
and in fact if y hat is
a vector with all of its entries equal
then
you'll also end up with the uniform
distribution
so now we can do erm with logistic
unembedding um
let's just uh compare with what we would
have done
in the deterministic
case in deterministic classification
we take our u's and our v's we embed
them as x's and y's
and then we use erm to minimize
uh the loss evaluated at g of x
i and y i the average loss over all of
the i's
and then we get the resulting predictor
by composing it with the embedding and
the unembedding
so if you give me a particular u
this should say u
so this should say v hat is
psi dagger g
theta phi
of uh
then i can i compose i take u i apply
the embedding to it
five u i apply the predictor g theta to
that
and then i unembed uh the resulting
output of g
theta to give me a v hat
and same here this quantity here should
be a u
um for probabilistic classification
we don't embed v
we embed uh u
using phi and uh
and then what we do is we minimize the
average
loss the average cross entropy loss
and here the two entries in the cross
entropy loss one of them is simply v
the true v and the other one is the
unembedded
value of the output of the predictor
so g theta of x i is going to produce a
y hat
and sigma of g theta of x i is going to
produce
a p hat and so the resulting predictor
is given
by uh
sigma composed with g theta composed
with phi of u
so the role of the unembedding here
is a little different the unembedding
lives inside
the loss function in probabilistic
classification
and its role is to take those vectors
that come out of our linear predictor g
theta and turn them into probability
distributions
let's take a closer look at our loss
function
let's suppose that we're unembedding
using the logistic
map the logistic unembedding so we've
got a predictor that produces a y
hat and we pump it through the function
sigma to get a probability distribution
p hat now let's look at the cross
entropy loss and say
we've got such a p hat and let's
evaluate
what the cross entropy loss at p hat v
k is so we've got a particular v
say v k that we're evaluating at
so what is that well the cross entropy
loss just says
evaluate the probability distribution
p hat at the point b k
so it's just the k entry of that
probability distribution
that's just the negative log of uh
the exponential of y hat k divided by
the sum of the exponentials of all the
entries
and that's the cross entropy loss we
could simplify that slightly
it's going to be minus y hat k
plus the log of the sum in the
denominator
and this is an expression that we've
seen before
this is simply the logistic loss when
kappa i is one
and so the logistic loss
which we used for
deterministic classification
um is exactly the same as the cross
entropy loss
when you use the logistic on embedding
and so if we're computing one we're
computing the other since
we're doing exactly the same thing and
so when we look at the
empirical risk that we are using
for logistic regression in the
deterministic case
that's exactly the average negative log
likelihood
and we can simply use the y hats
that come out of logistic regression
those predictions
are vectors but instead of unembedding
them
using the nearest neighbor map we
unembed them
using the logistic i'm embedding
p hat is sigma y hat and that way
instead of getting a deterministic
classifier
we get a probabilistic classifier
so that's nice it says that in some
sense
what we've been doing when we were doing
logistic regression
is actually computing a probabilistic
classifier all along
and now we know how to compute the
probabilities
um now we can we can interpret this
if we uh
look at what p hat is it's
well it's sigma y-hat and let's use this
in vector notation
x of y-hat here means the element-wise
exponential of the vector
y-hat and one transpose is doing the sum
for us 1 transpose x
y hat is summing over all of the
exponentials
and y hat here is theta transpose x when
we're
doing logistic regression and we're
using a linear predictor
then x one is one is the constant
feature
and we're standardizing all the other
features
um and that means that the first row of
theta theta one transpose
is y hat when
x 2 2 d is zero so
all of the non-constant features are
taking their
mean value and the corresponding
distribution is
sigma of theta one
then theta i j gives the effect of
x i on p hat j
and so that tells us in particular that
if
we uh have a very
large component of theta i j
then x i is going to be a significant
effect
on the probability distribution p h
now we can also do exactly the same for
boolean
classification we can do boolean
probabilistic classification
and we could just use the methods we've
seen so far
um but there's one special wrinkle that
people like to do for boolean
classification
and that is take advantage of the fact
that when you've got a probability
distribution over two
quantities you only actually need to
specify that by one number rather than
by two numbers
because the other one has to be one
minus it so if v
is the target set is v1 v2
and we're going to guess p hat is g of u
instead of just giving p hat com compo
of v 1 and p hat of v 2 we can just give
one of them
since they must sum up to one
and so we might give p hat of
v two which is the probability that v is
v two
and just define p hat of v one is one
minus p hat of v 2.
now if we're only going to need one
number
one probability then we only need
one component of y hat so if we're using
a predictor which is generating
a vector in our k but we're reducing
ourselves to
instead of needing two probabilities
needing one probability we can just pick
k
is equal to one or m is equal to one
and then we've got a scalar produced by
our predictor
a y hat and we want to generate
a probability out of that scalar
so that y hat could be any real number
what do we do
we take one on one plus e to the minus y
hat
this is also called the sigmoid function
and we will denote this by also sigma
and it's giving us a number which is
between 0 and 1.
it's uh
0 as y hat gets large and negative
and it becomes one as y hat becomes
large and positive
and so we're saying okay well now we
take y hat
we take sigma of y hat that gives us a
number between 0 and 1
which we will use as our
probabil prediction probability
for target value v1
and to get the prediction probability
for target value v2 we'll just take one
minus
sigma of y hat
and so we've mapped a real number to a
distribution on v which is exactly what
we needed to do
um and so this is called the sigmoid
function
the inverse map which allows you to map
from the probabilities
back to the y hat we don't need to do
that for
classification but that has a name it's
called a logox
log odds or the logit function
and here's a plot of the sigmoid you can
see it goes between
zero at minus infinity and to one
at plus infinity and it's half
when y hat is 0. you can also see the
symmetry
that symmetry is that if i take it and
rotate it about this
center point right here then
i get the same function and that's
expressed neatly here
that sigma of minus y hat is one
minus sigma of y hat
so let's compute exactly as we did in
the multi-class case
let's compute what happens if you use
the sigmoidon embedding
and you evaluate the cross-entropy loss
so we've got the cross entropy loss is
the negative
log of the probability
at vi and
well we know what sigma of y hat i is
if uh uh
and um we need to
um it's either going to get it's going
to give us two numbers
as our distribution you'll give us sigma
y hat
i for the probability
that v is v1 and give us 1 minus sigma
y hat i for the probability that v is v2
and so when when we're computing the
cross entropy loss we need to evaluate
this probability
at vi and so if vi
is v1 well then we get the first case
minus log
sigma y hat i if v i
is v2 then we get the second case
and now we go through into the algebra
and we see well
log of sigma is
sorry negative log of sigma is log of 1
plus e to the minus
y hat and
this is also something that we've seen
before this is
the boolean logistic loss
and so when we were doing boolean
classification
in the deterministic case we were also
behind the scenes doing probabilistic
classification
and the way one gets the probabilities
is by taking
the y hat that comes out of the
predictor and feeding it into the
sigmoid function
and this is the corresponding empirical
risk minimization problem
one on n times the average of
sorry the loss the empirical risk is the
average of the cross entropy loss
and the cross entropy loss splits into
two cases
the cases where v i is v1
and the cases where vi is v2
and we choose theta to minimize the
empirical risk as before
and once we've got theta theta transpose
x is y
hat and then sigma theta transpose x
is the probability that v is v 1 at
x and 1 minus sigma theta transpose x
is the probability that v is v 2 and x
now and this is simply expressing the
same
thing in a more convenient notation
where we've used the vector notation
here
let's look at a couple of examples here
we have
a two class problem three different
two class problems we've done empirical
risk
minimization and here we've plotted
the data points the red and the blue
data points there's no test or train
set here we're just using one data set
and there's no regularization
and we've plotted here in color
in the shading the corresponding
probability distribution sigma
of theta transpose x and you can see
that
it does what we expect it to do in the
middle
here along this line there's uncertainty
and the probability is half
as we move this way the probability of
red becomes one
red becomes zero or our equivalent
matrix probability of blue becomes one
you can also see that here in this
example in the middle
we've got data points where the blue and
the red overlap
considerably and as a result
the distribution
goes quite smoothly and slowly
between being quite certain over here
that it's red and being quite certain
over here that it's blue
and then a probabilities that are
somewhere between
0 and 1 in this middle region
and there's this wide band of
uncertainty
where the predictor cannot make a very
definite prediction
as to whether the
target variable is going to be red or
blue
here's a case where it's much more
separated and
there's a narrow band of uncertainty and
then very definite blue
very definite predictions of red
and this is the advantage of using a
probabilistic predictor over a
deterministic predictor is that the
probabilistic predictor when it's giving
you a
prediction of probability which is close
to a half
well then you can say well we're in some
region where
we can't make very certain predictions
and we're on the boundary and the
reality is it could be either a blue or
a red point
you can also see this in the matrix
in the vector theta so here
the norm of theta is rather small and
here the norm of theta
is much larger when the norm of theta is
large
well then theta transpose x varies
rapidly with x and so sigma
of theta transpose x varies rapidly with
x and the probability changes quickly as
we move
in this direction
over here because theta has small norm
then the probability changes slowly as
we move
in the corresponding direction
here's a three-class case this is the
iris data set
and remember what we had where
in this iris data set when we look at
these particular two
components of the data we find that the
red points are well separated
from the green and the blues but the
green and the blues overlap considerably
and it's hard to tell a green from a
blue
so on the left hand plot we're seeing
multi-class logistic regression
we're unembedding using the
nearest neighbor on embedding and this
is deterministic
classification and in the right-hand
plot
we're unembedding using the logistic map
you know sigma of theta transpose x and
we're getting out of that a
three-dimensional
probability vector which gives us the
probability of red
the probability of green and the
probability of blue
and what's showing up here is this is
the
level of certainty of the prediction
over here red is really very certain
then when we transition across this
line we end up
in a region where there's significant
uncertainty
so over here our prediction is one
zero zero
or close to that and over here
our prediction is zero a half
a half and there's much more
uncertainty we know it's not red but we
can't quite tell whether it's green
or whether it's blue
so let's summarize we use the average
log likelihood on the test data
to judge a probabilistic classifier this
is our performance metric
and it happens to equal the empirical
risk when we're using the cross entropy
loss
and there's a loss so there's a loss
function which exactly equals to our
preferred
performance metric
and once we if we're using a linear
predictor
and then we can unembed the prediction
into a distribution using the logistic
unembedding
and that gives us probability
distributions
and the deterministic methods that we've
seen for classification
using either boolean logistic loss or
multi-class logistic loss
with the one hot embedding are exactly
the same erm optimization that we do
when we do probabilistic classification
but to construct the probabilities
instead of unembedding
using the nearest neighbor map to get
the deterministic prediction
we unembed using sigma to get the
probabilistic
prediction